cette norme oms il est temps que la
nation française au prenne il est temps
que donc disais que la nation française
se vengent par la voix est l'organe
puissants de ces procureur général de la
république pierre desproges française un
peu qui reste suit n'est bonne humeur eh
bien monsieur le président est monsieur
le chanteur se vantant mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public chéri mon
amour l'homme qui nous fait face
aujourd'hui au ban de la famille est un
monstre mi homme mi chèvre 50 % de
matière grasse
ça vous va bien
alors là monsieur le procureur
vous vous rappelez vous me rappelez un
journaliste dont je ne veux pas citer le
nom d'un journal dans un journal dont je
ne citerai pas le nom mais qu'il
s'appelle ni seconde demi-heure
intemporel c'est l'un de ses
collaborateurs d'ailleurs c'est un
journal où il ya beaucoup de
collaborateurs et d'anciens
collaborateurs et il y a il attend
depuis de nombreuses années je cite son
nom puisque à chaque fois qu'il parle de
moi il m'appelle legros les trucs comme
ça mais c'est exécuté à monsieur qui
sort du lot télévision beaucoup
il attend depuis longtemps je parle de
lui mais je vois pas pourquoi je
parlerai lui ou alors fois je parle de
son physique comme je le connais
physiquement et qu'il ressemble à une
virgule qu'on met sur le mur des
chiottes
ce qui est normal pour un homme qui
écrit sur du papier qu en élevant à peu
le débat monsieur le procureur et bien
au départ mesdames et messieurs les
jurés sept hommes mille sèvres me
guillaume qui évolue comme une chèvre et
béland comme un homme au départ c'était
un enfant normal presque beau malgré ses
terres veulent qui ne l'a jamais quitté
mais c'est son éducation laxiste et
permissive dans un milieu parental qui
avaient fui ses responsabilités qui en a
fait les pas irrécupérable qui est là
aujourd'hui si je peux me permettre
oui vous avez eu de la chance julien ne
pas être le fils du procureur parce
qu'il vaut mieux être une épreuve qui
chante qu'un petit chien muselé voyez ce
que je veux dire
si je comprends bien sûr vie est-ce que
j'ai bien compris ce que je suis en
train de comprendre
ah oui j'ai eu des échos il paraît que
vos enfants vous appelle monsieur
tellement ils vous respectent
non non non non pas monsieur monsieur
papa toute façon c'est pour rire
ida pas rigoler tous les jours il paraît
qu'ils en même pas le droit de regarder
chantal goya à la télé est affiliée la
droite l'a bien sûr mais ça n'intéresse
pas
évidemment elle a plus de trois mois
maintenant ah ça veut rien dire
ça veut rien dire elle adore ça
d'éclater les marchés l'arête de tt
alors que toi tu arrêtes pattes ça
dépend qui c'est bien toi c'est toi oui
pour un non j'ai dit obscènes et d'un
autre côté tu as tu rda tesnière de
regarder chantal veille à la télé tu ton
amer enfin écoute cote quand ils seront
adultes ils vont regarder les
cochonneries qui voudront 1 mais pour
l'instant j'estime qu'ils sont encore
trop petit mais quoi
il y en a un qui a 16 ans et il pas
encore formés tu parles côté pas là il
regarde ce qu'ils veulent oui a pas du
tout quand je suis pas là je débranche
le post c'est simple c'est de la folie
il risque de s'électrocuter s'ils
veulent le rebrancher bien sûr mais j'en
assume le risque on n'a rien sans rien
je préfère ça que de voir ce que j'ai vu
l'autre dimanche chez toi ta fille en
train de regarder les nouveaux rendez
vous là je vois pas où est le mal dit tu
es aveugle ou quoi mais dis pas que ta
pas vu le cheval que jean rochefort a
mené sur le plateau des brugeois way à
la baraque où tu me dis pas que tu es
pas remarqué à quel point evry plaisait
au cheval se voyait vachement on aurait
dit qu'il y avait cinq pattes
la cour avait compris 22 précisé non
mais c'est vrai on aurait dit un cerf
[Rires]
qu'est ce que tu as contre un dessert
quitte à voir bambi autant le var on en
tienne
en tout cas moi mes gamines maintenant
la rue syrie c'est terminé
j'estime qu'on peut intéresser les
enfants sans avoir recours
systématiquement au sexe ou à la
violence
c'est très difficile ils sont très
branchés là-dessus non pas les miennes
les miettes elle adore les dessins
animés de tex avery par exemple j'en ai
enregistré plein magnétoscope
alors ça oui il aura tant qu'elles
veulent drogba justement parlons-en
le jour où je les ai gardés chez moi je
leur ai proposé de regarder des tex
avery et on dit si on n'est pas obligé
on préfère autant pas on les avis vraie
foi ça va comme ça par contre on
regardera bien le numéro 1 de chantal
goya voilà
et puis elle se sent passer la cassette
quatre fois de suite non mais là je suis
pas d'accord c'est désert je suis pas
d'accord parce que si je faisais comme
toi mes enfants seraient des vrais
drogué de télé il serait complètement
abruti toi t'es pas vous dîtes télé
peut-être ben moi ça risque pas je
regarde que le journal est aujourd'hui
proche
en tout cas je fais ce que je veux de
mes gosses
ce que je sais c'est que je risque pas
de les retrouver à trois mois au crazy
horse comme des gosses que je connais la
mienne elle va au plaisir c'est parce
que j'ai une copine la bac et la garde
mais qu'elle ait el lagarde d'accord
mais pourrait au moins la lâcher quand
elle monte sur scène elle peut pas à la
revue s'appelle crazy b
il faut un bébé dans combien tu loupes
200 balles ça lui paye sa garde
je trouve ça je trouve ça indigne de la
part d'un père de faire travailler un
nouveau-né si jeune et elle fait que les
matinées 1
un risque pas le coup de grisou puis
c'est bien que les enfants s'habituent à
bosser le plus tôt possible et voix du
monde sans quoi sa fédé mijaurée comme
les tiens le soir où je les ai gardés
appelles tu étais parti elle se sent mis
à chialer
pourquoi elle y avait en riz dès qu'il
ya un mec parmi les filles ont dit il
même si à 2000 filles pour un seul mec
ouais toujours ilp ah c'est pas mal ça
ça me ferait chier que ça s'arrête
non c'est un petit privilège qui mange
pas de pain c'est vrai mais dès que tu
es parti tout le monde qu'ils allaient
même henry qui a 16 ans maintenant oui
mais lui c'est pas pareil
ils m'adorent ce gosse il fait une
fixation sur toi carrément oui c'est
vrai ça toujours été un réel problème
pour moi c'est un garçon extrêmement
sensible déjà quand il avait 5 ans il
faisait des crises de nerfs parce qu'il
voulait porter une fausse moustache
comme rassembler et un moment je lui
étais obligé de céder je me suis rasé la
mienne tu as bien fait ça n'allait pas
du tout moi qu'est ce que t'en sais tu
m'as jamais vu qu'une moustache si on
arrive à montrer une photo je suis tout
pour cet enfant monsieur président
j'espère qu'avec le service militaire ça
va s'arranger quand même voilà attention
il va se retrouver tout seul à la
caserne 1 avec ta raison va peut-être me
que j'aille est cuit j'sais pas quoi
faire avec ses gosses un parole devient
chez un poids de chef qu'est ce qu'on
fait julien clerc un khawaja la lésion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait étonnant non